e se você já tomou algum remédio para
dormir ou para acordar se você já tomou
algum remédio para ter mais energia e
disposição para trabalhar ou teve que
aumentar as doses de café nos últimos
tempos Ou começou a receber mais
mensagens não só pelo e-mail ou pelo
WhatsApp mas mensagens do seu corpo como
uma dor nas costas a dor nos ombros uma
dor na cabeça uma dor aqui nos olhos ai
a gente precisa falar sobre
produtividade sustentável Oi Como assim
Isabela é assim se você ama o que faz
o E quero continuar fazendo que ama com
saúde tem uma dor aqui um problema ali
você precisa produzir trabalhar de forma
sustentável para você agora mesmo se
você ainda não está trabalhando com o
que ama mas quer procurar o lugar para
se desenvolver profissionalmente para
colocar os seus talentos a serviço do
mundo você precisa também pensar em
produtividade sustentável por você é
curioso porque a gente sempre pensa em
um planeta sustentável com lei
sustentáveis relacionamentos
sustentáveis todo sustentável Mas e a
nossa produção a forma como você está
trabalhando hoje era saudável esse
estilo de vida é duradouro eu só sei que
desde que a minha máscara de
mulher-maravilha caiu em uma fase em que
os
o meu tempo só para trabalhar e achava
que isso nunca me traria consequências
eu comecei a pesquisar os modelos de
trabalho e descobri que alguns podem ser
muito perigosos com o passar do tempo
porque as necessidades do nosso corpo
vão mudando também com o passar do tempo
mas muitas vezes não percebemos porque
ou estamos
é ocupado demais distraídos demais ou
vivendo no piloto automático pior ainda
é quando você percebe que tem algo
acontecendo que tem algo de errado mas
deixa para lá você pode fingir e fugir
do que você está sentindo por um tempo
você pode fugir se escondendo atrás de
filtros de redes sociais não abrindo a
câmera nas reuniões você pode se isolar
da sua família dos seus amigos por um
tempo mas vai chegar um momento em que é
impossível você fugir de si mesmo aliás
Renato Russo já cantou né que mentir pra
si mesmo é sempre a pior mentira olha só
E essa foto aqui foi tirada quatro dias
antes de eu ter um apagão ao vivo quatro
dias antes de eu viver um piripaque
enquanto eu apresentava a previsão do
tempo em um dos jornais da manhã quatro
dias antes de receber o diagnóstico da
síndrome de bournout que é O esgotamento
profissional que me fez acordar de um
modelo de trabalho insustentável agora o
que que estava por trás dessa imagem
desse sorriso todo taquicardia falta de
ar bruxismo problemas hormonais de pele
estômago intestino circulação tonturas
dores musculares pescoço travado crises
nervosas e ideias Suicidas
O triste é saber que tem mais de 20
milhões de brasileiros assim então As
Aparências Enganam não é mais de 20
milhões de brasileiros que por fora
estão muito bem mas por dentro estão
sofrendo calados muitas vezes porque é
muito difícil a gente explicar uma dor
que ninguém vê
Ah mas isso não significa que essa dor
não exista aliás tô para dizer que
aquilo que a gente não vê é muito maior
do que o que a gente vê a convide mesmo
é um exemplo disso você não vê o vírus
mas você não duvida não questiona o
poder destruidor dele não é você
respeita mesmo não vendo o vírus com os
sinais do corpo é a mesma coisa quer ver
outro exemplo você tá saindo de casa o
tempo tá armando para chuva e você deixa
a janela aberta você tá vendo as nuvens
escuras se aproximando você tá já vendo
ali os galhos das Árvores balançando tá
até sentindo o cheiro da chuva mas deixa
a janela aberta e até diz não vai chover
aqui não quando chegar para encontrar a
casa molhada então com o nosso corpo é
assim ou você vai ouvir as mensagens as
o seu corpo ou você vai ter que lidar
com os gritos de um problema de saúde e
o que contribui para esse cenário porque
a gente ouve aí sim ouvir como se fosse
um mantra que você sempre pode fazer
mais com menos que você deve superar os
seus limites custe o que custar
inclusive que tempo é dinheiro a gente
ouve também que dormir é perda de tempo
e que funcionário bom é aquele que veste
a camisa em tempo integral com tudo isso
a gente vai realmente perdendo a noção
dos nossos limites a gente vai se
cobrando mais esse negligenciando mais
e eu descobri se você quiser inclusive
já começar a pensar de forma sustentável
que você pode sim vestir a camisa da
empresa mas desde que você vista também
o seu pijama que você Vista uma roupa
para fazer atividade física sim você
pode amar o seu trabalho desde que você
se ame também Se comprometa consigo
assim como você se compromete com o seu
trabalho na prática produtividade
sustentável segue assim se você aliás
você pode né superar os seus limites
desde que você descanse entre um e outro
se você pegar pesado no fim de semana ou
por um período maior por um projeto
especial tudo bem desde que você pegue
leve depois Esse é o famoso equilíbrio
equilíbrio dinâmico equilíbrio que todos
sonham entre vida pessoal
a vida profissional Mas é claro que nós
Demoramos para reconhecer os nossos
limites como eu falei tem muito barulho
fora aí você não consegue perceber os
seus limites e não conseguem inclusive
demora para perceber comportamentos
tóxicos que você tem pelo excesso de
trabalho ao invés de descansar você
compensa o excesso de trabalho com o que
comida bebida drogas e acaba também diz
contando seu cansaço a sua insatisfação
com quem tá perto
a agressividade é um sintoma clássico de
quem já está seguindo por um caminho
sustentável Eu me lembro quando o meu
marido chegou para mim e disse assim
Isabela que que tá acontecendo você tá
muito agressiva E aí eu calmamente eu
respondi eu não estou agressiva
e na verdade eu tava cansada e tava com
medo eu tava com medo do que vão pensar
eu tava com medo de parecer fraca por
ter adoecido justamente por ter
trabalhado demais em um modelo
insustentável eu tava com medo de perder
o emprego naquela época era um já 13
milhões de desempregados
o e descobri que com o medo a gente fica
mais reativo cansa mais e produz menos e
eu descobri também que as pessoas vão
pensar o que elas são capazes de pensar
É sim as pessoas vão pensar o que elas
são capazes de pensar e não há nada mais
importante para sua saúde que as suas
escolhas não há emprego carreira salário
cadeira que resista a um estilo de vida
insano a um estilo de vida e
insustentável uma hora a conta chega
você querendo ou não foi por isso que eu
criei então o movimento da produtividade
sustentável para que você consiga
trabalhar para que você possa trabalhar
seja para um CNPJ ou empreendendo com
saúde sem ficar apelando para remédios
para você tá minas sem ter problemas nos
relacionamentos aliás Aonde a cetamina
assim como eu muitas pessoas buscam em
remédios drogas maneiras de suportar o
E isso não é resiliência tá resiliência
é bem diferente de apelação se você
buscar nas anfetaminas recursos para dar
conta do seu presente é a mesma coisa
que você colocar pneus novos em um carro
sem motor
e não vai muito longe Aliás a gente fala
tanto em longevidade felicidade
propósito mas e o equilíbrio como é que
eu vou conseguir pensar no futuro em
longevidade se eu não tô conseguindo da
conta do presente sim por quanto tempo
você vai continuar fazendo o que faz
então sem apelar para remédios e sem ter
problemas de saúde
Ah e não vai adiantar culpar o tempo nós
vivemos Novos Tempos mas o tempo é o
mesmo você precisa deixar de se iludir
com a possibilidade de ser multitarefa
de ficar fazendo cada vez mais coisas no
mesmo tempo isso é insustentável Então
você quer ver um caminho que você pode
estar seguindo de uma produtividade
insustentável tá aqui primeira coisa
como que está a sua necessário de
remédios tem gente que se vangloria né
de uma nécessaire cheia de remédios a
primeira coisa que você vai aumentando
nesse modelo insustentável é a
quantidade de remédios o vitaminas ou
estimulantes depois você vai Abrindo mão
das suas Horas de Sono para dar conta de
um dia longo de mais a sua noite vai
ficando cada vez mais curta
Oi Que hora que quem dorme menos de 6
horas por noite tem quatro vezes mais
chances de morte EA propensão a mais de
80 doenças outra coisa que você vai
Abrindo mão no modelo insustentável a
sua higiene pessoal vai ficando cada vez
mais rápida repara tempo de banho
escovar o dente vai ficando cada vez
mais rápida outra coisa que você vai
Abrindo mão é da sua alimentação você
vai comendo cada vez mais rápido e cada
vez pior alguém se identifica com essa
imagem Olha só digitando falando no
telefone e escrevendo e provavelmente
almoçando por fim
E você Vai Abrindo mão dos seus momentos
de lazer de atividade física você Vai
Abrindo mão da sua vida e passa só a
trabalhar até que virar um momento em
que um problema de saúde mais grave vai
te fazer parar e voluntariamente
justamente porque você considerou que
não poderia parar depois eu só sei que
eu comecei a me curar Depois que eu me
dei conta de tudo isso depois que eu
comecei a me incluir mais na minha
própria agenda depois que eu comecei a
ter mais consciência das consequências
das minhas ações
e eu só comecei a me curar quando eu
comecei a bloquear o horários para mim
ao longo do dia olha só que simples mas
Aparentemente parece difícil mas é aos
poucos que você vai se incluindo mais na
própria agenda é um exercício esse tá
difícil é porque precisa de treino eu só
sei que eu só comecei a me curar quando
eu comecei a atualizar a minha
identidade Sim a gente é atualiza
documentos com frequência não é a
fisionomia muda não muda
ou será que a gente só muda fora não
nossas necessidades vão mudando nossas
ideias vão mudando tudo muda o tempo
inteiro mas você precisa ouvir perceber
essas mudanças as gerações mudam o
mercado o profissional inclusive está
mudando o Home Office a tecnologia
conseguiram borrar ainda mais o tempo
fragmentando que já estava Ultra
fragmentado E com isso o que que nós
vamos fazê-lo sobrecarregando ainda mais
o nosso cérebro esse excesso de
informações vai aumentando as nossas
comparações você vai ficando mais
competitivo a pressão vai aumentando E é
claro que aí o cérebro vai ficar
sobrecarregado e fica difícil parar
bom então para que você Preserve a sua
saúde para que você Garanta a sua saúde
mental e consiga produzir de forma
sustentável Você vai precisar dar um
refresh na máquina na sua máquina nessa
aqui ó F5 aqui quer ver o caminho update
tá aqui ó quem é você hoje
e com a idade atual o que você precisa
fazer para viver bem quantas horas de
sono você precisa para ficar legal no
dia seguinte sem ficar se entupindo de
café tá Quais são suas habilidades
interesses hoje com quem você está
usando o seu tempo São pessoas e
atividades que fazem parte de quem você
é hoje ou de quem você era ontem são
essas respostas
o que vão te livrar dos ladrões de tempo
dos comportamentos tóxicos lembra que eu
falei são essas respostas que
milagrosamente como não passe de mágica
vão permitir que você encontre mais
tempo na agenda não para trabalhar mais
para se cuidar sabe por quê
é porque só o autocuidado é o
combustível sustentável que te liga ao
motor da vida sim
é só o auto cuidado aquilo que só você
pode fazer por você
não é sustentável para que você continue
fazendo o que ama com saúde se nós não
mudarmos a nossa mentalidade e
respeitarmos as necessidades do nosso
corpo nós vamos viver frustrados
profissionalmente você pode mudar de
trabalho mudar de carreira mas se você
não fizer por você aquilo que só você
pode fazer por você ninguém vai fazer
independentemente das mudanças fora é
claro que muitas empresas precisam mudar
várias coisas eu tenho conhecido algumas
inclusive que já já começaram nesse
movimento dessa grande mudança
profissional mas independentemente disso
não espere a mudança fora comece a
mudança dentro se atualize só com a
atualização de identidade você vai
alcançar a produtividade sustentável E
você vai deixar de sobreviver
ó e passar a viver
E aí